[Musique]
alors sa 100ème dire ah ouais pas mal
hein bah voilà ouais enfin c'est mieux
que l'ancien
tu vas en café un truc non c'est moi sur
le tournage alors ok voilà le tour c'est
possible ouaip et hop le minimum vital
télé console qui va mettre des étagères
ou enfin en plus tard non ouais petit
test murs
porteurs oui mur au porteur exactement
du coup lequel tu perces pour mettre des
étagères le pas porter même si la femme
de ta vie te demande de percer un mur
porteur pour rien au monde ryad tu
perces un mur porteur j'ai pas de meuf
donc je fais pas peur c'est
malheureusement basse et valider ces
semi valides et au caire face à l'egypte
à l'est ok c'est parti à part contre la
cuisine bah ouais traître est validé tu
me feras un café ce tableau n'est pas
tout juste vingt catégories juste le
café ico lydia dans le bac de
récupération donc je te tends à capter à
ma façon
je prends le losc à des renvois fin vais
prendre moi le frigo les alors quoi tout
nouvel et chaude qui veut me faire un
pays non le frigo il fonctionne pas trop
via le haut qui échoit le baquet
froidmont je suis désolé mais déjà c'est
pas logique ensuite toutes tes courses
elles sont foutues ça consomme une
énergie monstrueuse est pas prêt à vivre
tout seul tu veux pas en colocation est
quelqu'un pas bérenger tu veux pas
habiter criiad les
non tu as donné
j'ai peur d'aller voir la salle de bain
on peut s'arrêter maintenant obligés
d'aller vers la salle de vente ses
fonctionnaires à fonctionner elles
marchent encore son antiquité banc face
à la bête à 40° des faits garde parce
qu'à la fois je le retrouvais à l'autre
bout de la planète filtre
un filtre il faut le nettoyer temps en
temps parce que sinon ça ça fait des
eaux ainsi qu'aux petits peut nettoyer t
était nettement la dent fin c'est quoi
ce réacteur diffusé en fait c'est de la
récup c'était à ma mère franchement
c'est dangereux c'est pas très écolo tu
penses à mes enfants t'as pas d'enfant
non mais bon c'est jamais faim tu vois
dans le doute et je vais l'acheter
d'électroménager bon on va regarder
l'électroménager comme à ce qui paraît
ma machine elle est éclatée 1 ça coûte
cher de ouf mario c'est normal que ça
coûte une glande
s'appelle conseil doit voir des bons
plans mire oui c'est ryad vous avez
quelques minutes avait accordé
non ménagement se passe bien la partie
dans ces super juste est-ce que
vous avez des plans pour
l'électroménager tout à fait sûr
l'application fia qui a des bons plans
sur toute une sélection de
l'électroménager
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]